hi guys this is rahul from simply learn
and today i'm going to try to answer the
question what is machine learning
have you guys ever wondered how facebook
is able to perform facial recognition
or how companies are able to bombard you
with their products all over social
media
all of this is because of machine
learning so in this session i'll be
taking you through some of the important
concepts of machine learning
so first we'll talk about some of the
real life applications where machine
learning is applied
some of the challenges people faced
before machine learning came about
how things change for machine learning
over time why
you should be interested in using
machine learning what exactly
is machine learning some of the types of
machine learning
some algorithms of machine learning with
some simple examples
some of the breakthroughs that machine
learning brought about and what a career
in machine learning entails
you all know that machine learning plays
an integral role in our day-to-day lives
now let's talk about some of the places
where it's applied i'm sure you guys
need no introduction to netflix
netflix is where we get our daily fix
for shows and movies
now say you watch a show like game of
thrones now as soon as you're done
netflix recommends a movie like lord of
the rings
how is netflix able to make such a
recommendation
say you uploaded a photo onto facebook
now as soon as this photo is uploaded
facebook is able to tell who's in the
photo how's facebook able to do that or
how is facebook able to suggest friends
on the basis of the profiles you've gone
through your mutual friends
or the locations you've been to say you
just made an online transaction
using paypal now how does paypal know
that the transaction you made
is the legitimate one as you know there
are millions of transactions taking
place at the same time
how does paypal differentiate between
what is real and what
isn't so now that you know where machine
learning is applied you might be
wondering
how is life before machine learning to
help you understand
i'll take you through some of the
problems people faced before machine
learning
before machine learning became so widely
used ai systems were mostly rule based
which means that these rules failed in
real life scenarios
most of their state representations had
to be manually coded
and this manually coded was hand coded
as everyone knows hand coding
is quite difficult now the main
disadvantage was that
these problem scenarios or test
scenarios would fail outside what their
roles were coded for
that is they would not be very useful in
real life applications
even though they work pretty well inside
their controlled environments
so it's clear that things were pretty
grim before machine learning
so what changed let's take a trip down
memory lane to see how machine learning
evolved
over time can you think of a time when
machine learning wasn't so much a part
of our lives
50 years ago that would have been the
case that's not to say that machine
learning didn't exist back then
it was just that it wasn't so important
to them as it is to us now
so things began to change in the 1950
when alan turing came up with the turing
machine
now the turing tests determine if a
computer had real intelligence of its
own
in 1997 carrie kasparov the world chess
champion
was beaten by ibm deep blue which was
their ai
in 2010 microsoft connect was released
which was an accessory of the gaming
console xbox 360.
people could interact with computers
using their gestures
in 2014 facebook's deep face or face
recognition system was introduced
which could determine who was present in
the photo in 2016
google's alphago which is their ai beat
the world champion
at the game of go so what's next for
machine learning
the possibilities seem endless so we'll
talk about this a little while later in
further detail
now let's talk about why machine
learning is so important
and why you should be interested in it
machine learning has changed our lives
in several significant ways
let's talk about why it allows powerful
processing
which means it can process through far
more complicated data
hence the decisions that we make will be
much more well-founded and the
predictions are much more accurate
not only does it allow powerful
processing but also quicker processing
that is more work is done in lesser time
the outputs that we obtained are much
more accurate
now when you think big data you think a
lot of data now this
large amounts of data has to be stored
somewhere and when this is stored
it also has to be managed so with
machine learning you can perform
affordable data management
a machine learning method is also
considerably less expensive
the most important part is as we get
more and more data the more
and more complex it gets and machine
learning allows us to analyze
complex big data so what exactly is
machine learning
machine learning is a method that allows
computers to imitate
and adapt to human-like behavior so the
machine
analyzes past data learns from that data
and makes decisions or predictions
the computer is training itself to
perform the task the right way
based on everything it can learn from
the past data the computer is creating
its own logic and solutions
all of which without any form of human
assistance or intervention
these systems learn grow change and
develop themselves
when exposed to new data now that you
know what machine learning is let's talk
about some of its types
machine learning is divided into three
major types
supervised learning unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning
ever imagine how difficult email
handling would be if gmail didn't know
what was spam
and what wasn't your inbox would be
quite the mess wouldn't it
but this is where the first type of
machine learning comes in supervised
machine learning
now email clients like microsoft outlook
in gmail use spam filtering methods to
ensure that the users are kept safe from
spam
these spam filters are regularly kept
updated with the help of supervised
machine learning
now supervised machine learning is a
method where a model
after sufficient training is able to
make predictions for the future
in a way a question answer pattern is
formed a question and answer are given
as input
the machine learns from it and whenever
new data is encountered it's able to
make a prediction now take this image
for example
the past data is shown as a box of
triangles and circles
when new data which is a circle and a
triangle are encountered
the machine is able to determine that
the triangle goes in the box of
triangles
and the circle goes in the box of
circles now
let's talk about unsupervised machine
learning imagine you just added a photo
onto facebook now as soon as that photo
is uploaded there's a good chance that
facebook is able to identify who's in
the photo
and recommend this person be tagged in
the photo now this is done with the help
of unsupervised learning
now unsupervised learning only deals
with input data it
ensures that the data is more readable
and organized
it analyzes the input data to find out
patterns or similarities or anomalies in
them
this model is able to learn from
observations hence it's able to find
structures and relationships
among the input data now let's come back
to facebook
now how it's able to identify people is
by taking your friends photos
as the data set it then compares the
faces and the features of the people
present in your photo hence it's able to
identify who's in it
now take this image that you see above
as an example
in the input you have a collection of
circles stars and triangles arranged in
no
particular order so the machine learns
from it
it's able to identify the pattern and
then organizes data
as you can see the output is still the
collection of circles triangles and
stars
but now in a much more organized manner
now netflix amazon and several other
e-commerce websites use the same method
now let's talk about the last type of
machine learning
reinforcement learning what do you
observe you see that supervised learning
is about making a prediction
and unsupervised learning is about
finding a hidden pattern
but reinforcement learning works
completely different
it allows a computer to take a decision
based on past rewards for its actions
but this type of machine learning is
usually only to increase the efficiency
of a tool or a program now there are
three stages involved in reinforcement
learning
there's the decision there's the
feedback and the learning
now let me explain that with an example
of a game of chess the machine makes a
move
which is the decision then it gets to
know whether the move was a good one or
a bad one
which is the feedback then it learns
from the feedback the mobile pc games
that people play
are also made on the basis of
reinforcement learning that's the reason
why when you open up a game and replay a
mission
the same enemies you see before aren't
in the same place
each of these algorithms come under each
type of machine learning
now let's talk about some machine
learning algorithms
the main objective of a machine learning
algorithm is to solve a certain kind of
problem
so to solve each of these problems we
have a particular algorithm
so under supervised machine learning we
have the classification problem
and the regression problem and under
unsupervised machine learning we have
the clustering and the association
problems
so let's talk about each of these
problems in detail
a classification problem comes under
supervised machine learning
so what we require in a classification
problem is a yes or no prediction
questions like something belongs to a
particular category or not whether
something is broken
and so on it can help determine what
category
a given observation belongs to in the
simplest of terms
classification enables the machine to
classify something into a given class
a very important use case of
classification is spam filtering
now let's talk about how that works to a
given system we provide spam and not
spam emails
we talk about millions of emails now how
do they determine whether a given mail
is spam or not
it's on the basis of how often these
mails are received
how many of them have words like lottery
which are usually associated with spam
and how many of them have been flagged
as spam by users now this is given to
the computer
and it is learning from it after it is
learnt whenever new mail strikes the
inbox
it is able to separate them as spam or
not spam classification of this sort is
done with the help of the nave base
algorithm
now let's talk about the regression
problem that comes under supervised
machine learning
now in a regression problem we try to
predict a value based on past data
now you might argue that regression and
classification sound pretty similar to
each other
and you're right classification is also
determined on the basis of past data
now the difference is that in case of
classification we are trying to classify
an observation into a given category
in case of regression we're trying to
predict a value based on past data
also a relation is created between the
different variables
now let's talk about weather prediction
we have passed data like temperature
wind speed humidity and so on
and on the basis of that we can
determine how much rain was obtained
now this is given to the system and it
learns from it now when new data is
encountered
like temperature wind speed and humidity
the system will be able to determine
how much rain we'll get now one of the
most important things that you need to
remember
is that the output that is given at the
end of a regression problem
is always quantitative in nature also
the output that we obtain
is always on the basis of past data
the clustering problem comes under
unsupervised machine learning
clustering is a method where a set of
observations are divided into subsets
each of the subsets are known as
clusters now the observations inside
these clusters are similar to one
another based on some parameter or the
other
now clustering has found use in several
fields such as e-shopping healthcare and
financial services
clustering is different from regression
or classification as both of them have
some sort of prior knowledge associated
with them
but in the case of clusters all the
knowledge that's available from inside
the cluster
now let me explain with an example now
say a network provider wanted to set up
towers in a particular area
what they'd be taking into consideration
would be tower range local geography and
population
now this is given into the system the
system learns from it
and then is able to divide the area into
clusters
the clusters are divided on the basis of
optimal locations where towers can be
located
to ensure maximum connectivity for all
the users now a popular
algorithm that is used in clustering is
k-means which is used to cluster data
into k
clusters based on some similarity
measures
in the case of the association problem
we try to identify patterns of
association
between different variables and items
now this is commonly used in something
known as
the market basket analysis now this is a
theory that says that if you buy a
certain group of items
you're also likely to buy another group
of items
now the same concept could be applied to
the e-commerce industry
say you buy a set of books now the
system learns from it
and is able to suggest a new set of
books the next time you try to do some
shopping
now this is also used in the healthcare
industry before a new drug is launched
it is checked to determine
what kind of dna it is sensitive to
machine learning has brought about some
extraordinary changes in the last few
years
let's talk about some of them in detail
now ever since the dawn of ai
scientists have tried to ensure that
artificial intelligence systems
try to function like a human brain now
deepmind technologies which is a british
company
is one with a similar aim the company
now works on detecting eye diseases
using machine learning where a digital
scan of the eye is created to determine
if it has any diseases or not
when it was acquired by google in 2014
they created a computer network based on
the structure of the human brain
they also created a neural network that
could play video games on its own
alphago is an artificial intelligence
system that was created by deepmind
technologies
on the basis of state-of-the-art machine
learning techniques
alphacode defeated the world's best
player at the complicated game of go
now the latest version of alphago which
is called alphago zero
only requires scientists to input the
rules of the game for the system to be
able to play on its own
now this is different from the previous
situations where each of the move
patterns
had to be input into 40 processors for
the system to be able to play the game
can you imagine how comfortable our
lives would be if cars could travel from
one point to another without any sort of
human intervention
thanks to machine learning and
artificial intelligence this dream is
becoming closer to reality
now a self-driving car is one that
travels from one point to another
without any sort of human intervention
the self-driving cars have several
components some of the most important
ones
are these self-driving sensors now these
detect curbs in other cars while parking
there are lidar sensors that monitor the
edges of roads and lanes there are
cameras that detect traffic lights
pedestrians and other things on the road
there's radar that monitors the position
of nearby vehicles
now as i mentioned before let's talk
about the future of machine learning
in the future you'd have deep
personalization which means that you'd
have more directed marketing towards
your interest
and advertisements based on your
personal preference
self-driving cars although it's a
concept that's being worked out right
now
it's not one that's reached its
completion in the future you'd have cars
that can run flawlessly
even on the most crowded roads smarter
investment opportunities
machine learning could ensure that your
profit is maximized taking into
consideration your past purchases
and the current market scenario to
suggest smarter investment opportunities
better medical diagnosis although
healthcare is a field where machine
learning is creating an identity
slowly but steadily it's not reached the
point where personalized solutions can
be given to patients
in the future machine learning could
change that i'm sure many of you are
interested in building a career in
machine learning
now let me tell you about some of the
career prospects someone skilled in
machine learning fits the shoes of a
machine learning engineer
a machine learning engineer aims to
create artificial intelligence
now the programs they create take
decisions on their own without being
programmed to perform a particular task
now what are the skills of a machine
learning engineer mathematics the
concepts of mathematics
help deal with uncertainty and making
reliable predictions with the help of
the tools that they provide the
fundamentals of statistics
since most machine learning algorithms
are built on statistical models
knowledge in this field is very
important software design
a strong background in apis of various
kinds like web apis
static and dynamic libraries are also
important
applying machine learning libraries and
algorithms now understanding models the
learning procedures
how packages apis and other things work
their potential issues and how they
apply to each technology is very
important
data modeling now it is critical that
the concepts of data modeling be
understood well
to ensure that the algorithms that are
created are sound in nature
programming languages since there's a
large amount of computations to be
performed on huge sets of data
it is necessary that concepts such as
algorithms data structures computer
architecture and so on
are understood well now what are the
responsibilities of a good machine
learning engineer
data engineering that is to ensure a
good data flow between database and
backend systems
using programming languages to run
machine learning experiments with
machine learning libraries
to deploy machine learning solutions
into production
implementing custom machine learning
code and performing feature engineering
which is nothing but performing an
analysis over the data pre-processing
and several other processes
the graph here indicates the trends of
job postings in the field of machine
learning
although there's a sharp dip mid-2016
the spike indicates that there's a
strong interest
in hiring skill personnel evidently
machine learning provides greater
opportunities
in terms of the job they can provide
google trends show an increased interest
in topics related to machine learning
the machine learning market size is also
expected to grow from 1.03 billion
to 8.81 billion dollars by the year
2022.
this indicates a bright and clear future
for the individuals killed in the
concept of machine learning
now let's go through everything you
learned in the video first we spoke
about what is machine learning
which is a method where computers
imitate and adapt to human-like behavior
these systems take decisions on their
own based on past data
we spoke about the types of machine
learning supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning
supervised learning where a model is
able to predict outputs based on past
data
unsupervised learning where we detect
hidden patterns in input data
and reinforcement learning where the
system's next course of action is based
on past feedback
we then went into machine learning
algorithms we spoke about some of the
problems that these algorithms solve
under supervised learning we have
classification where we determine a yes
or no prediction
regression where we predict a value
based on past data under unsupervised
learning we saw clustering where
observations are divided into clusters
and association where we determine
patterns of association between
different items or variables
we spoke about some of the breakthroughs
that machine learning brought about
like deepmind alphago and cars that
drive themselves
then finally we spoke about the skills a
machine learning engineer needs
which were mathematics the fundamentals
of statistics
software design applying machine
learning libraries and algorithms data
modeling and programming languages and
that brings us to the end of this
session
i hope you guys enjoyed it put your
doubts and feedback in the comments
below
and stay tuned for more videos from
simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here